l'europe centrale et est composé de
petites nations qui ont longtemps vécu
sous le joug d'empyr et qui tiennent un
assez de liberté du mans conquise qui il
s'appelle en d'autres termes la
souveraineté et qui ont une conception
de la nation plus culturelle que
juridique dans les fait comprendre que
c'est effectivement contrairement à la
nation française qui a été construit de
parent et a créé existe à l'état où se
sont même construit contre l'état
puisqu'elles ont longtemps été dominée
je les dis par des empires juste au
siècle dernier et cette définition
culturel de la nation vous l'a retrouvé
dans la dissidence un ranch totalitaire
chez millan kundera voulais retrouver
durant l'entre-deux-guerres
en tout un ensemble d'intellectuels et
vous la retrouver aujourd'hui face à une
union européenne que viktor orban
définit comme un ordre libéral un ordre
libellé et libérale qui ne considère que
les individus et non daily nation et qui
cherche à construire une forme de
supranationalisme sociétal qui mettrait
en cause l'héritage culturel issus
notamment de nos racines chrétiennes
racines chrétiennes sont rappelés dans
la constitution et donc au fond si vous
voulez moi j'aime bien rappeler sa
phrase de paul thibault qui expliquent
le populisme c'est un conservatisme qui
a perdu de sa légitimité
je crois que à l'est le conservatisme
n'a absolument pas perdu de sa
légitimité puisqu'il correspond à une
demande qui est le produit de l'histoire
et un sentiment que david à hilla a
justement rappelé la peur de disparaître
la peur de mourir
la sensation que ce qui est fondamental
est fragile et donc méritent d'être
défendus et donc aussi nous avons aussi
à travers la notion de deux droits
fondamentaux une vraie différence
nous avons une acception plus libérale
des droits fondamentaux à l'ouest nous
avons une acception qu'une nationale
conservatrice de ce qui est fondamental
à l'est là aussi je crois qu'il faut
quand il faut en tenir compte pour
construire une europe qui va de paris à
dison
varsovie ou plutôt bucarest pour prendre
les tables vous allez
[Musique]